ridiculous
um Brian Callan actually talked about
too lazy to try
because well let me guess does he not
because honestly I've watched too lazy
to try right this guy does not Crush
puss or play sports that's the problem
too lazy you don't crush puts or play
sports that's your issue there bud weeks
ago I made a video talking about how
Stephen Crowder has been humiliating
Brian Callan and I played this clip that
Steven posted to his Twitter account of
this video where Brian is dressed up as
a cow and some guy is spanking him well
he's going moo and I was concerned I was
like all right this is weird whatever's
going on here especially after all this
stuff that's come out about Steven
Crowder so I talked about that in a
video and then during a recent fighter
in the kid podcast that they titled
Steven Crowder made Brian Collins mother
cry Brian brought up my video and he
said that's what made his mother cry she
watched that video and I guess she got
really concerned about him so if that's
true if I made his mom cry I'd like to
apologize I'm sorry Mrs Callan you know
I was just worried about the little guy
and I'm glad you're concerned as well
but it sounds like Stephen he's taking
good care of him watch it in the whole
cow suit thing you know that was just a
funny bit they're doing I was taking it
too seriously sorry I have a
pedestrian's brain I don't understand
comedy that well
pedestrian's brain and like Brian a
comic spray is so different than a
potato I [__] broke what a hack is it
just me or is like too lazy to try
starting a little more fired up I'm
loving it well it's fired up as
we're too lazy to try fires up but it's
like when orange Cassidy fires yeah yeah
you know what I mean it's still he took
his hands out of his pocket that's
basically it like too lazy to try is
definitely gonna bring the championship
belt to the ring in a backpack yeah and
so during the podcast Steven didn't make
him get in that costume he chose to be
in that costume my mom called me very
upset she said there's a video that says
Stephen Crowder's been humiliating you
and put you in a cow suit and I said Mom
and I created that video he never I know
I said he's never humiliated me we get
along very well oh we've seen him I mean
you're lying Callan we've seen you get
the shut up light you've been snapped at
you've been yelled at oh he's such a
liar if anything it's the opposite and I
put myself in that cow suit and then she
went she goes why and I go I thought it
would be funny
was it though
I like to push the arms we miss and
sometimes
sometimes we miss Brendan you've never
hit anything in your life in the UFC or
otherwise no I mean you didn't even hit
the bottoms of Ronda Rousey
oh what Dana White had to go in there
and play cleanup
um watch it [__] watch it uh five
dollars it was his last fight to a guy
that [__] her too I mean to be fair
like everyone [__] Ronda Rousey that's
not fair that's not fair you know
you miss oh what he lost a fight to
Vince McMahon okay see he's a comedian
that's just trying to push the envelope
and he's having fun with it you know and
if he likes dressing up as a cow if
that's what he wants to do I think we
need to be more accepting of that cow
people if if you want to identify as a
cow there's nothing wrong with that and
I'd hate to contribute to the bigotry
that those people have to deal with so
if Brian wants to put on a cow outfit
and get spanked and move once in a while
I'm not the one to judge I'm glad he's
open enough to do it although I will say
at 56 I had a cow suit on and I staged
that whole thing I was like do this whip
me and I was like I'm 56 and I'm doing
this this is not this is not a good look
so you're admitting he admit it he
admitted you have to marry your mother
at all I want to sue where the others
just fly off
but sometimes you got to push yourself
he's thinking I am better at this than
you
I don't have no it's funny silly being
silly and then it also gets at taken out
of context too so if you just see that
what context Brandon what what what
contest Papa what what context would
would you need the cow suit to be in
like like they're legit whipping you as
a cow it's like oh you know so oh great
you know what I apologize
wait wait out of the conversation
Brennan fantastic you know it's like a
thing bro okay got it dude God thanks
man thanks for expanding your Lexicon
hello knows the con it was a bit he does
bits on there all the time he's just two
bits the video is out of context
obviously but that's how Steven posted
it to his Twitter account he said just a
normal day at the office and it's him
walking in the door seeing Brian Cowan
getting whipped by some Cowboy so I
think Steven kind of outed him with this
video so that's why I think he should be
taking most to heat here you know I
think he's the one really responsible
for making Brian's mom cry I don't want
to have all that put on me I was just so
apparently the show that uh that Landau
is doing he's doing with quarter black
Garrett and they post they posted it and
I actually quote tweeted and I go I hope
this this show does great just to piss
off Steven Crowder quarterback Karen
liked it oh boy yep yup he's just liking
the well wishes yeah no I'm sure it's
the well wishes or well maybe that video
that we had about the emails maybe it
was crowdsourced I don't know if that's
true or not I'm just honestly just this
the theory that I have who knows stating
the facts and I was concerned for the
guy I think Steven should be treating
him with more respect and I think
Brian's mom agrees so for whoever writes
mom agrees super made that brilliant
video I didn't see it but apparently you
clipped it I didn't see it he's so like
he didn't see art remember we didn't see
ours he didn't see our videos
huh when I sent it to the group chat oh
you did yeah yeah and we all made fun of
you okay well they made somebody made
the video clipped it up you made my mom
cry you son of a five second clip Brian
how do you clip it up
tell me
I'm a [__] good video though
congratulations
I haven't seen that video good video
very funny these people are so creative
yeah somebody made an amazing video away
just like Brian Callum is being
humiliated yeah but it but it
there was no
it was not really we watched the video
it was the clip from Crowder posted
now as a transition scene on my OBS for
night wave chroma key same here and I
didn't have to change anything I just
went to oh I I typed in download of
Twitter video
that's just what I used
utter also owes Brian's mother an
apology you know they titled the podcast
Stephen Crowder made Brian's mother cry
so it sounds like they agree with me so
I think on the next show that Brian does
with Stephen he should ask him to
apologize to his mother all right so
before I wrap up this video I just want
to mention how I figured out that Brian
talked about my video because that
podcast is like four or five days old
but I just heard about this yesterday
because the fighter and the kid or the
tfatk YouTube channel and posted a video
about it you know the YouTube channel
that talks about the fighter and the
kids saw brought it and reads the
comments and stuff they posted a video
because they thought Brian was talking
about their video but I guess it was
mine and they did give me credit for it
so I appreciate that I appreciate you
giving me credit for making Brian
Count's mom cry that's great now but
seriously I wouldn't have heard about
this if it weren't for that so I guess
that is good that they talked about it
and they gave me credit all right so
that's about it for this video thanks
for watching make sure you leave me a
comment let me know what you think about
all this I think that you have way too
much energy I think you need to relax
[__] needs to calm down man I will
say this I've always said about too lazy
to try utterly unhinged crazy man he's a
crazy man that doesn't know how to stop
like I I've you know I've meant to send
some messages and be like man look you
know you don't want to the last thing
you want to do is [__] you know have
a goddamn stroke or a heart attack over
this this universe on the Internet it's
not worth it